some of you have no sense of smell yeah
yeah is that something that happened
recently no no no no in all my life I
don't think I've ever had it I don't
think I've ever had it and it's like you
know then I mean that's how you taste
everything it's how you're supposed to
yeah orally at least the nuances like I
don't get any grace notes you know I
wouldn't be I wouldn't be great on like
a you know a judge on like you know Iron
Chef or you know right top you'd in fact
you might be the worst chef yeah or or
olivia has the theory that I should go
on one of those because if they can get
me based on like texture or like I like
sauces or whatnot that I that they've
done something very very is the question
I've always heard that people who lack
one sense the all the other sentence has
heightened you know if you if you don't
have a sense of smell or if you can't
see that you know you can feel right
everything you can smell everything
we're here everything is that true for
you it is not just so you have no
superpowers that come with having no
smell no nothing zip zero in fact I
would say I mean like yeah I know I wear
contacts and glasses I my my hearing is
a little bit impaired from doing the
mini rock concerts without using
earplugs because that ain't rock and
roll right yeah and taste obviously
affected touch you know it's suspect
based on you know put even your sense of
touch is go yeah you know I mean yeah I
just it hurts to feel things yeah so
yeah it's it's it's a misnomer but
here's the crazy thing is that I don't
have with the thing that I'm really
tripped out about now is that smell is
such a trigger for people's memories
that I have a weird I can't remember
what things taste like so like if you
put a piece of chicken and turkey in
front of me and had me taste one and go
what is that I wouldn't be able to tell
you which is which you could then tell
me chicken okay great and this is Turkey
okay great and then if it's like if I
did it within another 30 seconds I would
know which is which like if I did the
Pepsi challenge I'd have I'd be screwed
so which then I'm like okay well this
makes sense why I will always go back to
my one of my first loves Taco Bell
because I'm always I'm always I forget
what it does to me an hour after the
fact
or the next morning when I'm you know
have it because don't I love that's the
worst celebrity endorsement I've ever
heard for a product Jason Sudeikis
I love Taco Bell because I can't taste
it I'm open for business TV give this
guy a call it also begs the questions
about farting yo yo well did you did you
like how did you know what you doing
what are you doing this is where the
real shows to not fart in a car in a
closed car well yeah because there's an
audible clue to know and I saw literally
dude growing up I would just like
someone would fart and some would and
you don't start doing this and I would
just oh yeah oh just play along
oh so tragic and then and then at some
point I did I realize oh aw like it's
okay I actually this is I get the fun
part I get the free part but it was in
the second city touring company van when
someone would rip one and everybody
would go nuts I can taste it you know
like how people do and they when you're
in a little tiny van is like nine adults
and I would just be like oh that's gross
at some point I was like no I can't
smell it it weighs like a record scratch
wah you can but yeah what's tragic like
iope things turn around for me sometimes
they will
you